what is going on there citizens of the
rejection
we are going to watch she-hulk episode
dose today thank you for joining us john
how's your day going it's getting a lot
better now good to hear koi sun how is
your day going very well you're wearing
the same shirt as last week yeah i know
that's how i do and koi knows how
microphones work sometimes
that sounds like a pilot on an airplane
it's nice having koi back here with us
since i'm doing so many solo and quite
you know you guys are watching those
koi's comic corners they're great i also
follow him on tick tock there's a lot of
stuff over there he's always asking me
to plug it and i'm like shut up i call
them at midnight
yeah guys i'm gonna be wearing the same
green shirt and daredevil for the next
nine weeks
i'm committed until our marvel shirt
comes in from shop zero edition.com then
i might change it up but this beanie
stink alrighty people listen up leave a
like
smash that like button subscribe and
click that notification bell get
notified when i react when the next
she-hulk is up okay that's serious
business here full-interaction watch
alongs recycled with the time code
meaning your own copy over at our
patreon page for super sexy rejects
cover a bunch of crap over there
exclusively as well and
prepper team thank you guys for helping
set this down let's watch the marvel
sketches show a stunning scene from the
metropolitan courthouse super influencer
can you tell us about what you saw today
yeah yeah yeah so this chick
pretty decent
like like a chick
a she-hulk
exactly
[Applause]
that's for somebody called she hulk
which can't possibly be what they're
calling me lady hole girl hulk she hold
come on just give them what they want
[Music]
so dumb i can't even exist without being
a derivative of the hulk that's a pretty
dumb name too hmm
neat little trick you pulled there
walters but don't you think it's a
little unsportsmanlike to suddenly debut
superpowers just to drum up publicity
for yourself only you would think that
seriously how did you get these powers i
really don't feel like talking about it
nepotism you knew it
jesus let's check over there i'm gonna
go talk to it
it
i relate to that guy
you could be an avenger
do the avengers offer health care
maternity leave a pension it's a big
problem tony had jen can i talk to you
for a moment of course sir
what is that
could you uh go back to jen jen this is
a serious conversation
uh
sure
all the booze in her system that's great
we didn't win the case oh yeah we did
glk and had a declared a mistrial
because you as your uh like
she-hulk that is not what i call it how
is it her fault what was i supposed to
do like let them get hit in the face
with a desk and then they have blunt
force trauma and they're all bleeding
out all over the courtroom floor no
i'm sorry oh
i'm sorry two boss
no jen i'm sorry i have to let you go
what jeez wait
wait you're firing me
oh my god a logo hey
[Music]
oh i hope that keeps up that motif we're
not prepared to offer you the position
at this time
sorry
it's a no
we just can't take the risk of a
sideshow
that was clever at the background
getting the lesser and lesser seeming
offices so so smart
montage
good observations
film comic book reference
jen what are you doing eye on the prize
come on seriously said iron man 3's is
that what it said no
what fire it again captain america's ass
that's her phone background
[Music]
some of this production design reminds
me the matrix because everything's just
so great
there is no spoon jennifer walters you
don't have to worry about getting fired
i already told everyone so it won't be
awkward
oh no
hi everybody hi jen you're gonna fire
him chad chad ted
so to bring it up i said don't bring it
up it's okay dad i yes got fired but
it's fine big news so i got uh promoted
to manager over at the best buy manager
all right chad enjoyed and promoted
employed and promoted that hawkeye guy
what happens to those arrows of his i
mean does he go around and collect them
when he's done jenny nobody calls me
that i'm just gonna put this out there
melanie
is a stylist you know
she could help you let's get this hair
more like she-hulks
oh hazardous believe those things lying
around
you know like i thought i could keep
this at bay
for i don't know how long
eternity well but it's just like i hate
we're loving thunder
the thing that you were dreading
happened but look you're still standing
and now you get to keep moving on
me too
he's a nice guy mobile on the tv because
the show's like that
easter egg ally mcbeals canon now
i'd like to offer you a job
ah is this a joke
don't ever joke
it's no easy feat against glk h
so
i would like you to come work for us
you got me fired now you want to hire me
to be head of a new division yes take
some time i accept
i
will only do it if i can hire my own
paralegal
non-negotiable
i truly do not care who your paralegal
is yes
that's a building
established
tall
structurally sound corporate
we just started a super human law
division and i want you well the
she-hulk to be the face of it oh uh that
means i'll expect you to be at work and
in court
as the she-hulk
not as a normal person
right now poor choice of words can i
change
this way please
we are the first top-tier law firm to
launch an entire division dedicated to
superhuman law
god is this why they hired me okay this
sucks i am totally qualified but now
everyone around here comics
these dodos never had to deal with this
on their first day at work but i'm
curious
what do you think about it i'm
uh agnostic
interesting
unprecedented for sure
spend the rest of the year worrying
about what i just said no it's good look
at everything it's getting us
big-ass windows yes a fully stocked mini
fridge and
a desk
i mean this is normal but this this is
very fancy bit
she's great hey i love her hi there i'm
pug i'm also in the superhuman law
division oh i'm i'm jennifer walters i
made you guys a welcome basket oh that
kind of looks so familiar it's adrian
chase romero it's andrew's history i
didn't realize it's not my second
viewing snacks and
a map to the best bathroom
thank you
the live deliveries of this show are
very good
and then um
tell bob thompson that he's going to
minneapolis because he hates the cold i
mean just tell him that mr holloway i'm
so
i can't wait to take on whatever case
you want to assign yourself first case
is the parole of emil blonsky
get right to it oh also known as
abomination mr blonsky has been serving
his sentence in an ultra high security
prison i am very familiar with mr
blonsky sir i'm sorry but i can't
represent him this man tried to kill my
cousin bruce yeah that's quite all right
welcome
kind of neat how our clothes don't
really rip do not step past the yellow
line do not touch the glass separating
you and the prisoner abomination
although we have taken every precaution
we cannot guarantee your safety do you
accept these conditions yes
sign here we haven't seen him mia
blonsky in so long so long it's hitting
me right now because we saw him as
abomination in chongqi but we haven't
seen him
yeah since 08. jennifer what was
first off
namaste
i was expecting abomination right you
won't be seeing much of him about
honestly i've completely transformed
myself physically obviously but
also spiritually
i'm simply a male now russian born
british raised royal marines commando on
loan
to the u.s government okay with seven
soul mates that i met through the prison
pen pound program that i want to start a
new life with
nice
let's talk about the elephant in the
room shall we
your
cousin the hulk
[Music]
you know i
tried to kill him you know so let's get
that out of the way it wasn't personal
or anything so
i was under direct orders from your
government but then you went on a
destructive rampage in harlem
that wasn't sanctioned by the government
yeah because they pumped me full of that
super soldier serum the serum the
government gave you caused your
subsequent actions oh
i thought i was gonna be you know
captain bloody america something
you know and
now that
very threat your cousin is held up as
some kind of hero and i'm
locked up in here i like this screen
yeah thunderbolt setup right here
the parole board's gonna need to know
that you feel remorse for your actions
to even consider release
absolutely i do see and
i have here
uh various haikus that i've written oh
boy
tons of remorse the sorrow oh you don't
have you'd like to experience them
that's okay
if i were your attorney i would advise
you to speak truthfully from the heart
instead of trying to gauge what you
think they might want to hear that's all
from my heart
jen
look
i just want to
move on with my life
live in peace on a large piece of
property purchased for me by my seven
soul mates right
think you can help
yeah i'll think about it thunderbolts
[Music]
hey jen what's up
bruce hey um listen i got a new job hey
congratulations that's fantastic yeah
but but part of the deal is i have to
take on emil blonsky
as a client and and i i couldn't do that
without talking to you first okay i mean
it doesn't seem like you hold a grudge
at least you've never talked about that
before
and and you're always saying that you
know everybody deserves a second chance
and and i'm not falling for an act here
he was so compelling and and maybe i
want to believe
that he's reformed you know isn't
[Laughter]
but rehabilitation of that matters
i think you're calling me to tell me
you're taking the job i'm calling you to
tell you i'm taking the job yes
that's great jen you should
actually blonsky wrote me a really nice
letter a while back and a really
heartfelt haiku
and that fight was so many years ago i'm
a completely different person
[Laughter]
they just acknowledged
oh fourth wall break well used i'm a
completely different one literally i end
up naming you anyway
don't
even
no
i love that
that's got a nice ring to it she-hulk
attorney at law yeah that's the title
dips this show you coming to l.a anytime
soon
yeah probably not for a minute i got
some things i got to take care of
oh my goodness
always on planes
i've already got a winning strategy and
it is a hundred percent in the bag glad
to hear it uh you might want to take a
look at the news right
yes just the general news so far there
have been no statements made by emil
blonsky's attorney after shocking
footage
what appears to be an underground fight
club after having somehow oh [ __ ]
yeah
that sucks
[Music]
oh what oh
damn oh such a good cliffhanger they're
so good oh
we better get a mid credits with the
haiku
that was such a good cliffhanger this
show's very good it is very good
it's my
assessment yeah i think they uh i think
they eliminated um
by a little bit a second episode i i
liked it more than the first one for
sure
there's a lot more i think they just
needed to establish the world quickly in
the first one an hour in
yeah
it's really well done first one was kind
of like a prologue
to get hurt
into the world this is like the real
first episode yeah exactly this is what
the show will be like from now on
this this is different than the yeah
just the first opening and then and
there was a shield logo on that one
yeah like some of them are the same but
others are being updated there's like a
little hulk movie in here
oh
side hulk story
or is it just a big setup
you wonder if they're just like yeah
they're setting something up is it just
every episode bruce is gonna be
somewhere else random or is this yeah
spin-off territory i think that's all
the roughly we might get i don't know 4k
is this thing nobody does but you still
need it dude i don't know what i'm doing
down here
i'm tired i've turned to the left i'm
turning it right look 10 o'clock
i don't know
drop it down rub it down
do not touch these wires again no
i could have done that
there you go watch out for the lamb
[Laughter]
i'm glad you're staying hydrated dad but
this seems a little excessive oh yeah
do that yep okay
[Laughter]
i like this show i do too all right koi
has a heart out in the next nine minutes
no no
this is how it rolls when koi is here
i'm the problem
[Laughter]
you
always yeah
white man always hope
hiring people for the wrong reasons
right this was strategically planned for
this year yep greg
commentary jesus guys
wait
you should go first oh no i went first
last time drums go first you should go
first uh yeah no no no i really really
enjoyed this
toy
what did you think
sure this is how i lose the reject
nation
pitting us against each other is how i
believe yeah pick your favorite one he
tried to do it with eric voss and it
didn't take so now he's trying to do it
with john yeah like i like i mean i have
too much fun sometimes johnny okay
state your opinion
for the jury
defend why you legitimately like this
show uh no no yeah yeah i agree i liked
that this built well upon the first one
that it really does establish i mean you
know i'm sure they'll throw us
curveballs and surprises but it feels
like now we have the tone of the show
complete
and i really liked uh
what they're sort of getting at with um
both just showing the struggles that she
faces and i'm sure a lot of women face
you know as they build a career and as
you you know you it's hard to do the
right thing sometimes and sometimes
you're not rewarded for doing so and
then how they relate that over to emil
blonsky and his situation and i don't
know what this whole prison break thing
is going to result in i want to still
believe that he ultimately will be a
sympathetic character but i really like
that they had that thing to connect over
of like hey i was just put in this
position of
you know i thought i was doing the right
thing i thought i was the good guy and
here i come to find that i've been
manipulated and turned into you know
this this force and so like i was like
oh cool like that's a kind of universal
and a mutual uh identification moment
that i thought was really nice and uh
and spoke to and also getting hired off
of her looks
well yeah there's yeah that too it's
like it's not about what you know or
your expertise it's about you know yeah
the the appearance and it's about us you
know i'm sure you know having you know
we're the first ones to open up this
progressive new office and we want you
to be our poster child like yeah there's
a lot of that sort of corporaty uh you
know false
uh uh posturing and virtue signaling
sort of uh nuance going on there and
things like that but i'm curious too to
see how uh her relation i feel like
that's gonna be a interesting sometimes
harsh sometimes fun relationship between
her and her boss but the show did
establish that she was gonna win before
that whole fiasco happened yeah that's
just so she actually is skilled like
it's not solely just because of her
appearance yeah yeah but that she was
gonna
actually win it itself yeah
all right coy
go
i love that this felt like a goddamn
comic book not only did it have that
like single frame that felt like you
turned the page and there's like the
thing you experienced from chung chi
which is very comically like the the use
of the interwoven world in the mcu has
always been very well handled but now in
phase four i feel like we've got
multiple timelines that are happening
simultaneously like with the end of
hawkeye where we had you know the
spider-man moment i love that this is
feeling like a world it's feeling
fleshed out so we get shields journey
carrying forward we get that tie into
where it lies in time loud chung chi but
we also get a launching point for hulk
so this this really feels like when
you're reading marvel comics it all
feels like a big tapestry i really love
the character growth i agree with greg
that the first episode and it's actually
funny the things that i forgave about
the first episode i i had those three
things that were qualms still loved the
episode but i do feel like that was
worth it to hurry to this episode too i
love that this is nine episodes because
now we have eight episodes of this
because episode one just kind of got us
there like it was like hey love their
chemistry love this relationship you're
gonna love shield we're gonna let all
this fly by i would have loved if the
pilot was like 45 minutes even 10 more
minutes of just like her struggling her
succeeding a little bit more of of those
things we talked about but then it's
worth all of that for eight episodes of
this attorney show like i'm genuinely so
excited for where this goes and i've
loved most of the marvel tv shows but
this one
feels like the most
like a show like i i feel like i'm
watching a 90s show
that happens to be a character i love i
this feels like when i would watch stuff
with my family and be like and next week
i'll come back but it's not something i
love so it's combining my two great
loves like watching stuff that i enjoy
with my family and comic books that's
actually part of its strength uh weirdly
enough because a lot of times with these
big shows there the pitch is always we
made like a six-hour movie yeah
and then sometimes it feels like it's
kind of caught now in between being a
show and being a movie so that at times
you're like i wish it was kind of longer
now or maybe this didn't need to be as
long so actually embracing the fact that
it's a tv show i think the boys does
that well and this is just gonna say
boys they took that eric cripp keynote
of maybe instead of writing your six
hour movie you should write six great
episodes of tv yeah and i think that's
what they've done here is because this
is this is really strong i i like that
they give like the thing that we were
talking about the first episode of not
really having much of a struggle that's
going to be more of an internal struggle
that's carried over here and 10 times
more you know her getting fired because
it's like the last episode ended on look
again not another struggle super villain
shows up whoops the super villain's ass
not a problem yeah and then it picks up
right here and it's like oh that's
actually a major problem for her of
everything that just occurred and you
know feeling objectified too off of it
and yeah i like the commentary on be
like see to me
that is a little bit more of just that i
know this is already i'm not going to
spend forever talking about that camp is
going to have a [ __ ] issue with it
because it's like yeah the writing of
episode one with some of that felt like
this could have been more fleshed out
and more nuanced and and instead of just
feeling like okay you're just kind of
talking to me and here they're carrying
over that commentary in the work field
in the you know pr field in the image
field they're carrying over that type of
commentary but in a way that i actually
feel is imbued within the world and
makes a lot of sense and doesn't feel
like i'm being talked to and so i really
liked it that's kind of a little bit
again if they had that like ten more
texts yeah that first episode then i
would have had i wouldn't have had kind
of that criticism towards some of that
dialogue but here i think that it's
actually done really well i don't feel
pandered yeah i know there's gonna be a
lot of people who automatically already
gonna feel like oh my god
but leave
don't don't be here
um because this this right here i'm like
no that's the right touch because it
also has this really sweet tone to it
like i really enjoy the tone a lot i i'm
not familiar with ally mcbeal like i it
was a show that existed and i saw
commercials for all the time when i was
a kid but i didn't actually watch the
show i know you saw the practice because
you had someone who worked on it his dad
was dead i had a guy
and sliders have you heard of sliders
the movie about people in portals
it's a series it was a series of jerry
o'connell yeah oh no way that's awesome
i love jerry o'connell and other things
he worked on the thing back in the day
that's awesome he was a trainee yeah
that's crazy
didn't know any of that learned
something about james
dot com
john
of the humphreys
and one thing i'll say is to add to the
actual conversation my dad's rad uh but
but yeah uh one thing is uh with the
pacing and the nuances and things like
that often times during these scenes
whenever i have a a like a notice moment
it's always like i could tell that scene
went on longer and they trimmed it down
so i feel like it's all there but one
thing that this episode made me realize
that's been great about phase four i
think in particular is you look at like
shangchi you look at miss marvel you
look at this they're really great at
doing best friends and family
environment and just like plopping you
in like some of those family scenes i
wish did have more time again just
breathe because they do become just like
here's your large character note however
cliche yeah
and so like during that scene with the
dad i was like okay i get somebody
probably was like we need to speed this
up but i wish they could really have a
bonding chat back and forth but even
despite that i thought the actors at
least and just the kind of environment
they drew for those was really nice and
touching and i hope for the i hope they
could get to that miss marvel level like
oh we're really spending some time with
them and that phone call with bruce is
so good yeah that was such a great use
of both those characters and then the
reveal was excellent i think
the way again i'm i'm bringing them up
because of the two most recent shows or
no no let me do it again i'm bringing
them because of the two most recent
women
what gets more engaged the two most
recent it
yeah things things the two most recent
things to be here
[Laughter]
no but imam valani and tatiana maslany
they
there's there's that kind of quality
okay i need i need to make sure i say
this properly um
okay paul rudd as ant-man i'm like i see
paul rudd still you know what i mean
yeah um
there's certain characters with some of
these roles that i'm like wow they are
just this person like they are that
character they are this person and i
feel like both the man vulani and
tatiana maslany they just are them sarah
and the casting team behind this they've
found these characters they're brilliant
performers like they're so
they're so nuanced without relying on
like being nuanced
i am the actor
because they keep so much life and real
relatable personality and they just
sound so [ __ ] natural when they're
talking and so i love i i absolutely
love her performance like i'm just
watching her at all like dad she's so
good and she makes up for a lot of when
the because again the same i feel like
whatever thing i said about cgi in the
first episode is going to be applied
here sometimes it's going to look good
so i'm just going to look a little off
whatever but it's not as distracting to
me because i'm so um i'm i'm enjoying
the show so much that i was like
whatever it's the game
yeah i'm going to own i i didn't watch
uh orange is the new black uh is that
that's her show right the uh titanic
lonnie
she had a show where she played multiple
character shows she had a show where she
played a lot of different characters and
i didn't watch it but i did see her in
stronger and she's incredible and
stronger but it's a very very dramatic
performance so i didn't have a lot of
exposure to her in a comedic role and i
know jennifer walters from the comic
book being one of the first characters
to break the fourth wall in a major
comic book she is she's
she is nailing it yeah and i didn't know
i had i didn't have enough exposure to
her other work that i just like knew hey
i know she's a very strong actress i've
supported her as she'll from the
beginning because of stronger but now
seeing her comedy in this i want to
watch the thing she's known for like i'm
i'm now a fan of her to be like i want
to go retroactively discover the glory
that is her work yeah she's freaking
brilliant so good experience the
mausoleums yeah
and like i'm appreciating i appreciate
the way they are building out this world
because it's done it does feel like a
comic book show and it's done in this
really i don't i can't quite find the i
feel like everyone's already said it in
this discussion
i'm so happy this is really snappy it's
snappy it's enjoyable and i found myself
wanting more like when it was done not
not in a bad way like when it ended i
was like i wasn't expecting it to end
nor did it end abruptly it ended in a
way i'm like no i wanna i wanna keep
watching that was really enjoyable when
a show does a good three-act structure
that you're like i didn't even notice
that it was almost over because i'm
actually in oh no cliffhanger like yeah
and instead of trying to do this six
hour and a six to nine hour movie thing
they're allowing for a
specific journey
per episode you know like where she had
to come to with a place of acceptance in
the first episode and then here you know
having to deal with these things and
then confront bruce about having to deal
with the decision and then also now that
she's out in the public there's like
little journeys little arcs in between
each one there's lessons to be learned
in each episode and so i think that is a
big strength already demonstrated in
these last two episodes and uh i i
really like um i like the whole thing
with the lawyer division i'm sure that's
that's a comic thing right now let's see
what happens is she's representing
superheroes and i could see that you
know folding in uh you know obviously
daredevil but also even things like
jessica jones as a private eye that's a
superhero that could even lead the
awesome and like the heroes for hire uh
this episode was called attorney for
hire even talk about that i can see luke
cage
there was this
quote going around on twitter about
this either director or writer talking
about how they would take these
characters who uh were often really
serious in these films and they get a
chance of playing the tone of she-hulk
and of course that led to a lot of like
comedy what what they're terrible
hilarious uh so that's what it is
so
to see what to get a flavor of that with
emil
i was listening to his monologue and i'm
like no he's getting some of that humor
in there it's not too much they haven't
joked him up to the point where i'm like
now i'm laughing at emil blonsky and
this the speech he was making i was like
you know what you're making a really
good point actually
you were the hero they hired
that movie but he's a hero in the show
um potentially yeah yeah hulk exactly
yeah because because emil blonsky in
that movie they were like we're the one
we need you to hire we're gonna inject
you and fill you up drug yourself in
that movie performance is all like
eyebrow
mustache twirling and here he is a hero
yeah so i think that they did uh i want
to make sure that sometimes you're
talking about emil and hulk or are you
talking about both i'm talking about
emil in hulk in hulk yeah i'm saying in
the film this is the show in the film
swirling his mustache swirling villain
in the sh in the movie in the movie but
he was he's making a point though that
is true was that they hired him thinking
he'd be the hero who could take down the
hulk which is the beauty of nuanced
characters yes like kingpin and
daredevil like this is that i think they
they wrote that in so well because to
put that in the context of his
perspective and to watch how he's
changed and you give him actual
personality that's freaking tim roth
he's an amazing actress
a great actor during that scene i was
sitting there thinking oh man he must
actually be having like a a good
enriching time performing
right
especially with those recent quotes from
like mickey rourke about like you know
about his time working with marvel and
like ah you know they're not willing to
go in and give us some character to
actually work with i was like it seems
like they have learned to really do that
with their especially veteran actors and
and their new talent too yeah it gets
something more fun and interesting to do
instead of just like you i won't i want
more yeah like this
[Music]
give us
give us the haiku
i hope that's like a publicity thing i
hope you like get it out there in the
world so yeah i thought that was that's
an it's a very fascinating chapter to
explore now it makes sense why wong
would be getting into trouble yeah a
lawyer too because oh these shang chi
things are going to have repercussions
and i really think it's setting up
thunderbolts
that whole speech felt like oh we're the
good guys oh my seventh
come on it's right there i mean they've
already established that thunderbolts
are coming right it's just like i just
didn't think it would be like in his
first minute of screen time yeah i think
they'd be like and this is the
thunderbolt setup and i was like that is
so yeah i'm enjoying it a lot and i
think that the show is doing a really
it's a really fun time it's it's genuine
it's like genuine sincere
fun with a lot of heart and
in a way that also keeps them
mcu growing yeah man i think that's the
thing that a lot of the times that we're
we're sort of wanting is like you know i
do want some of that mcu world building
as well and it's but it's not like
solely dependent on that yeah and yet
you're also getting that you're getting
to have your cake it doesn't feel
shameless it doesn't feel like it's like
oh you use this character you notice
that you're nerds like it feels like
it's a useful tool it's the appropriate
environment to do a lot of this and
that's why i think the cameos in this
and i though some of the comments in
that koi's comment corner watch it uh
about cameos in the show i think you're
gonna feel good because they've already
done it so well i think this is the only
way to have some c and d list characters
that like i'd love to see incorporated
give me stilt man i don't want to see
stiltman anywhere else but like this
would be a great way to do a lot of
those characters in tone
scar is coming scar so he like beat the
person with the ship yeah that that's
weird to me i don't know who was flying
that ship he's gone now he's just like
annihilated out of space
maybe they came to a peaceful agreement
or maybe there was no one in that ship
and it was automatically autopiloted
yeah they opened there's jessica bloom
as a hologram being like my champion
you're under contract all right guys
well um hey before we go thanks for the
patreon
adelia chamberlain
you
are more than a she-hulk yo you're a
greg hulk oh that's what i call you
right so adelia um you might know of her
koi oh um
she helps run uh let's get ready to
what's it
called
yeah good she also got my discord she's
a she's a swedish oh so you do know
adelia she's awesome
yeah she's the best she's a sweetheart
she actually like i don't know how to
use a discord and she's been very
patient with my being very dumb yeah
she's she is a big heart and soul of our
patron she's been with us forever had
some very long conversations with her
only met her in person that one time at
this moment
it was good chilling with you though
yeah so i i think what i've learned
today ideally is koi knows who you are
i appreciate you i thank you for your
patience i think you're very very kind
and welcoming to people in the movie
world and that is not always the case
and i think you're a great bridge
between us folk that are having to deal
with
not great people and the good like
everyone you've connected me to has been
rad you're a great gateway to the people
we might not meet otherwise and we
appreciate you
i like how you counted the things you
were listing i like to make sure that
people won your kind
[Laughter]
all right adelia all right see you guys
thank you for being here bye bye i like
lists i'm a virgo
[Music]